wir haben nämlich jetzt bei uns bei bild
live zugeschaltet aus düsseldorf karl
lauterbach ein mann also der macht hat
der minister ist hier in berlin und der
herr lauterbach sich heute als
wahlverlierer fühlt fühlen muss
ja das ist tatsächlich so guten abend
wir haben die wahl klar verloren das ist
traurig dass eine wahl ziel wurde
erreicht nämlich schwarz gelb abzulösen
aber wir haben nicht ausreichend
mobilisieren können um für die eigenen
inhalte genug also wähler also an die
urne zu bringen das ist eine große
enttäuschung alles andere wäre falsch
das muss man einräumen trotzdem über
monate hinweg war also rot grün das
wunschbündnis der bewohner hier in
nordrhein westfalen der wähler
vielleicht reicht es am ende ja doch
noch für diese möglichkeit das ist die
einzige hoffnung die ich noch in den
abend hinein tage glückwunsch an die
grünen in ganz besondere art und weise
haben einen fantastischen wahlkampf
gemacht und haben überzeugen können
glückwunsch auch an die union die union
hat es zum schluss geschafft zu
mobilisieren zulasten der fdp und damit
sind wir konfrontiert sie sagen ganz
klar wahlverlierer ist das dann
moralisch trotzdem regieren zu wollen
das ist ja keine frage der moral sondern
eine frage der inhalte wenn es zum
beispiel so wäre das also die grünen und
die union nicht zusammen kämen weil die
grünen haben das großartige wahlergebnis
ja auch bekommen weil sie gegen die
inhalte der union wahlkampf gemacht
haben also wenn schwarz-grün nicht
zusammenkommt dann wäre die inhaltliche
schnittmenge bei also rot grün natürlich
viel größer übrigens auch eine andere
viel größer somit also moralisch
ist das auf jeden fall wenn man für
seine inhalte auch nach der wahl noch
kämpft und eine solche regierung könnte
ja noch zustande kommen aber wie gesagt
es gehört dem mut dazu man kann so etwas
jetzt nicht verlangen sondern man muss
abwarten richtig entwickelt von der
landtagswahl können die
spitzenkandidaten im land mehr
entscheiden ob sie den rückenwind aus
berlin nutzen wollen ob sie dann kanzler
zum beispiel mit auf dem plakat haben
wollen oder nicht in dem fall hat die
spd entschieden jahr wollen wir wollen
den olaf scholz mittel auf dem plakat
haben und wir wollen den so oft wie
möglich auf der bühne haben hat nicht
funktioniert
ob das wirklich der grund ist das wage
ich zu bezweifeln war es waren ja im
wesentlichen landespolitische themen die
bestimmt haben schauen sie sich das
ergebnis der fdp an die schulpolitik
hier in nrw hatte
die fdp aber sich linke nicht ab ich
glaube das ist eine inhaltlich zu
treffende analyse dass es in der
schulpolitik der fdp quasi ihr ende
gesehen hat bundespolitische themen
haben auch eine rolle gespielt dass gar
keine frage aber olaf scholz macht halt
eine sehr konsequente
und aus meiner sicht auch richtige
ukraine und moskau politik die es nicht
immer populistisch das ist auch nicht
immer in ihrem blatt vielleicht dass der
gewünschte weg aber er will die
bevölkerung nicht gefährden will aber
trotzdem eine klare kante gegen russland
zeigen wir sind nachts in den
vereinigten staaten sind wir dass da
etwas verlässlich die meisten waffen zum
beispiel liefert aber wir wollen nicht
ins risiko gehen und was ich an der
politik schätze die wir aus ampel hier
machen wo du hast alles angefangen wir
wollen nicht für populistische kurse
geländegewinne bei umfragen die
bevölkerung gefährden wenn das so stimmt
stellt sich ja noch mehr die frage warum
es kein kanzlerbonus gibt also wenn das
stimmt dass aus der sicht der
bevölkerung der olaf scholz komplett den
richtigen kurs macht ist ja noch ein
größeres fragezeichen warum gibt es dann
kein kanzlerbonus
ob es keinen kanzlerbonus gegeben hat
das werden die analysen zeigen die haben
weder sie noch ich es vorliegen das muss
man auswerten aber die hat man sich
einen gewaltigen folgen die grenzen kann
ist ganz einfach da brauchen wir gar
keine analysen den kanzlerbonus gäbe
hätte die spd heute überragen die wahl
gewonnen weil bei der bundestagswahl war
die ganze nrw kam
die niederlage also die niederlage muss
ja analysiert werden welche rolle da der
kanzler gespielt hat wissen sie nicht
das weiß ich nicht da kommen noch andere
aspekte noch hinzu habe ich will so viel
nochmal in den vordergrund stellen wenn
es darum geht also abzuwägen ist man
populistisch oder also schützt man die
bevölkerung geht konsequent aber nicht
risiko also
risikobehaftet vor dann ist das der
richtige weg also wir haben aus ampel
hier aus meiner sicht verantwortungsvoll
gehandelt davon haben über das auch die
grünen profitiert wir haben eine
gemeinsame politik hier vorgetragen und
somit also muss man hier die nerven
behalten im moment profitieren die
grünen in der ampel das können aber bald
auch wieder wie es seien zum beispiel
bei der niedersachsenwahl kann ist ganz
anders aussehen ja aber dass auch die
fdp in der a 40 wieder gut erholen kann
daher das kann man jetzt nicht also dass
davon nicht überinterpretieren wollen
den kanzler marlowes erstmal noch in den
analysen suchen anschließend in den
nächsten tagen und wochen aber dann
suchen wir doch vielleicht in lauterbach
maar los bei dieser wahl in nordrhein
westfalen also wie groß ist ihre schuld
mit der in den sand gesetzten
impfpflicht die sehr unbedingt wollen wo
sie den kanzler auch ein stück weit rein
getrieben haben mit dem quarantäne chaos
und so weiter also wie viel es ihre
schuld
es gibt keinen quarantäne chaos sondern
also die isolation pflicht ist ja
geblieben und damit haben wir uns
durchgesetzt und also ich hab den bundes
kannst du auch nicht also in die
impfpflicht gibt also getrieben sondern
er hat von sich aus schon bevor wir die
koalition gebildet haben hat er die
endlich für richtig gefunden da waren
wir einer meinung da bin ich immer der
gleichen meinung wie urlaub chance
gewesen ich glaube nicht dass die also
pandemie politik hier das wahl ergebnis
negativ beeinflusst hat ich habe selbst
also hier im wahlkampf viel zustimmung
erfahren also dass also begegnet mir
jeden tag auf den straßen ich bin auch
kein unbeliebte also minister auch bei
ihren eigenen umfragen übrigens nicht
ich das so sagen darf somit und übrigens
wenn jemand von der pandemie politik
tatsächlich also nachteile erlebt hat
dann war es tatsächlich die fdp ich bin
nicht sicher ob es der fdp hat wenige
tage vor der wahl die masken pflicht
also weg nehmen zu wollen in den
flugzeugen oder im op en v das sind
maßnahmen dann merkt der bürger hier
will man populistisch noch mal kurz vor
der wahl einen raushauen aber die
bevölkerung will eine konsequente
schützenden kokon napoli also die korona
politik hat keine rolle gespielt im
wahlkampf und hat dann doch eine rolle
gespielt damit es nämlich dass fdp
wahlergebnis zu erklären sagt carter
eine frage noch weil die hier gerade in
der runde auch schon aufkam sie haben
ziemlich
langsam licht malen lassen sie mich kurz
ich lasse nämlich kurz korrigieren ich
habe gesagt dass die pandemie collette
politik keine große rolle gespielt hat
beim schlechten wahlergebnis der spd ob
es bei der fdp anders war das habe ich
zur debatte stehe somit konstruieren sie
kann den scheinbaren widerspruch also
dass gehen wir zu schnell zu ihrem satz
in der rheinischen post herr lauterbach
sie haben sehr habe ich ausgeteilt gegen
die cdu und sie haben diese sätze gesagt
die impfpflicht hätte alles einfacher
gemacht das wissen wir dass das ihre
position ist die union trägt die schuld
wenn die impflücken zu vermeidbaren
toten und beschränkungen führt nehmen
sie das zurück
nein wieso sollte ich das so bleibt
nehmen das stimmt ja auch also wir
hätten wenn die union also mitgemacht
hätte im deutschen bundestag und hätte
die gewissensfrage tatsächlich
zugelassen hätte das nicht zu einer
fraktions abstimmung gemacht es war es
ja jeder der nicht wie die impfpflicht
durch bekommen oder die
wahrscheinlichkeit wäre sehr hoch
gewesen alle also ministerpräsidenten
wollten dass die mehrheit der
bevölkerung wollte dass alle
vernünftigen wissenschaftler worden dass
ein paar ausnahmen aus an hier also
nicht mitgezählt also somit die
impfpflicht hätte uns geholfen und wir
werden natürlich im herbst also probleme
haben die wir ohne die impfpflicht also
jetzt bekommen und sonst nicht also
gehabt hätten hätten wir die endlich
durchsetzen können wir uns das erspart
geblieben darauf habe ich hingewiesen
dass es weder falsch noch also
unangemessen man muss ross und reiter
sie haben der cdu ganz offen die schuld
für künftige tote zugeschoben das ist
schon ein krasser vorwurf nehmen
trotzdem mit ihrer erklärung dazu r
lauterbach danke an diesem wahlabend zu
ihnen nach düsseldorf